okay four people joining this livestream
this is a bit more of an infrastructural
discussion than we often have um it is
about publishing directories of files in
the cloud and so we have a candidate
function cloud published directory we've
got some background noise both over here
um okay so let's let's start in on with
the issues here and um alright so the
basic story is that we've got a
directory in the local file system and
we want to publish that as a directory
in the cloud right yes and furthermore
we might want to do so repeatedly as we
update contents right but when we say
we're publishing to a directory in the
cloud let's look at what those URLs end
up being so this is the case where
basically that URL um let's just see how
that works
let me see um so we just want the
production oops what on earth happened
there to the production cloud
well is that a routing problem from my
machine okay that's a super bad start it
works for me though it's not generally
down but Matt can you yeah III seem to
be able to get into the cloud from here
and say Lois so I mean a different
browser so can i oh
however this thing lost my login again
from you know what I would well okay so
let me try
oh now it worked so that was a stray 500
error okay in any case so the URLs that
we're dealing with here so like if I go
to my files and I go to published and
this is this is a separate issue is how
we're dealing with the top-level
directory here versus the sub
directories but let's go to published
and let's go to whatever whatever the
heck this thing is but let's let's some
I don't know what this is um but anyway
you see the URL here right
it says slash published slash directory
at mustache file right yeah okay so what
we are imagining is that cloud published
directory would be writing a directory
name followed by file names under here
correct rights okay so there are two I
mean there's the one argument case in
the two argument case and the one
argument case refers to you know pushing
to a subdirectory in quote the default
publishing location which I imagine
publish directory okay whereas whereas a
two argument version could put it really
anywhere right now but this idea of
deploying I mean there's no reason why
cloud deploys and also have this
directory moving capability right
isn't that this has nothing to do with
the permissions for publish this has to
do with the idea of turning essentially
a filesystem on on the desktop okay so
they're they're different there are
multiple concepts here you know turn a
filesystem on the desktop into a
hierarchy of URLs in the cloud right
that's one thing uh-huh another thing
would be um even take this take this
file system you know perhaps in the
cloud and publish it okay and copy it to
publish it am I making sense which
presumably cloud publish already does
for an individual file not a cloud
that's right um okay so that means these
are two different things right I think
you're related but okay so this one
could have a cloud deploy version uh
Jana you here you can you comment on
this yeah I mean the thing to keep in
mind is that right now both cloud deploy
and cloud publish I think I have no
opinion on you on your local filesystem
right they take an expression like a
notebook expression and publish that
it did not really suit you saying okay
or or any expression I mean that's given
a string they published a string yeah
okay so then there's a separate destroy
the string as you say sorry right the
separate issue is take a file and deploy
slash publish it right you're saying
that we don't even have that concept
right yeah not not in the form of car
deploy our cloud publish the way you
would do it right now is using copy file
I see which is kind of ugly I mean okay
so right now we'd say copy file and then
you'd copy it how does even know okay so
my first women is a plain string which
refers to your local file system and the
second argument would be a cloud object
okay which is what a directory or that
so oh that's an actual final destination
cloud object that's the final
destination exactly so it you know the
usual rules for out objects applies if
you give a string inside there it's
relative to your cloud directory which
starts as your user directory and so on
okay I'll give an an ominous cloud
object okay so we actually need another
piece of functionality which is um I
mean really what you're telling me is
that we need a cloud deploy file which
take um you know could take a notebook
object or a filename and deploy it so
the way that would work is it would look
like cloud deploy file and then it would
be a file name and that would deploy to
an anonymous cloud object you know you
get the idea
yep um we now just use the file wrapper
for cloud deploy itself so what does
this function do that cloud deploy of
file of path wouldn't do well we could
do that yeah we could do that
unfortunately we don't have a wrapper
well I mean we can know whether that
path is a directory I don't see the file
wrapper documented in cloud deploy
that's not where we're just inventing it
oh okay okay sure I mean what's
interesting about that is it would allow
things like cloud deploy of local object
does that work right now well copy the
file of local object works right now
okay but this could be made to work yes
okay um I kind of liked this idea of
making it be you know so then because
then we don't have to replicate this we
just say cloud publish a file of
whatever it is and then um and then we
don't even need a separate cloud
published directory do we that's a
question still read John I think you
said that they were still enough
different options that well so I mean
the you know these these two options
that I've outlined not cloud specific
which I've called clean publish I know
you don't like that name and file types
these are not things that
we would want users to be compelled to
write on their own then their useful
functionality I think ok fine but but
let's look at um I mean
yeah so we also have this notion of
clouds synchronize right where did we
get to with that um depends on what you
mean by that so there's you know many
people probably think of a two-way
synchronization between a local file
system and the cloud house system
yes we didn't really think about that
okay what did we what are we calling the
one what are we calling the one that was
the one way synchronization we don't
really have a name for that yet I mean
it could either be just copy file and
copy directory doing you know stuff more
intelligently or maybe with additional
options okay okay so this is the 2-way
version so then the question is the
one-way version you know synchronize
cloud files with local you know from
local right or even the other direction
but only in one direction you wouldn't
try to know merge notebooks determining
what the newer version or something like
that you would always overwrite what
you're saying is it's it's a it's some
kind of you know cloud update but it
isn't really that either because it
could be okay so you're saying this
could be wow that's pretty funky it
could be local from cloud okay so it
would be something like okay so it's
something like update a directory in the
cloud from a directory on the desktop or
vice versa
now in your practice what you really
want I think is to register the
correspondence and then poke it it
you see what I'm saying maybe right
because I mean basically not I'm very
unlikely to want to change that I mean I
might at some point want to say okay let
me back it up by synchronizing to
something else right but most of the
time it's like this cloud you know but
mostly you know mostly want I would
think what I would want to do once you
pick a base directory then sync
everything relative to that am I making
sense didn't we discuss that you already
do do we have notes from what we
discussed or did we discuss this two
weeks ago didn't we
Matt can you comment on that please oh
look but I don't think there's anything
well you would have been taking the
notes I didn't make the notes were you
not taking notes then Andrea typically
takes notes that meaning where is Andrea
it's Andrea not here no she's not here
oh can you get her please if that um um
but you wouldn't want a single base
directory right you want to be able to
let's say
publish multiple packages each from
their own directory no no what I'm
saying is what I'd like to do like like
my file system is pretty well organized
on the desktop okay what I'd love to be
able to do is to have the exact same
file organization in the cloud
yep and I don't want to have to rethink
oh I'm gonna have six new based
directories I just like I've got the
same base directory you know like you
know I mean I can I could pull out my um
what's a good example here you know like
like my um well my SW notes directory
okay so I could perfectly well say I
just want a copy of this as you know
these will be reasonable basis I want a
copy of that in the cloud
sir I'm saying I'm describing each
individual thing I just wanna say
everything under that I want to um um
that's one use case I think they
shouldn't only support that use case
what's another use case you you should
still be able to not publish everything
in the in the directory basically or you
know pick arbitrary relations so I have
package a in one location package P in
in another location and but I don't want
to publish everything around them that's
fine I see I see so one thing ok then
sync everything relative to that so
another case is or might want to sync
particular directories but the question
is whether those directories have their
paths be the same or whether those paths
are changed did you get what I'm saying
your package a might have a path that's
file of all levels deep in your desktop
file system do you want to replicate
that path or do you want to put it
somewhere different you might want both
things I think right um Oh
okay but um why is the still not done
sorry I'm sorry just one second here
um call our livestream says you can't
participate in the stream but he'd like
to beg for cloud blog publish really
wants blogs specific functionality yeah
we're working on some related things
we're definitely working on that for
computational essays and so on different
different topic um not a hundred percent
different though
you
okay
um okay alright so let's go back here
um this question about so we've got this
idea of deploying from a file to UM ah
suppose somebody who isn't on mute is
making all kinds of background noise um
thank you ah okay um
okay so first possibility is this kind
of thing here cloud deploy have a file
path
um and um
honestly this seems pretty on
travursel the only issue is what to do
with these other options so let's look
at what those other options are that has
to do with what to do with the target
so cloud publish already has this issue
about whether um well it's it's not
quite the same I mean you know question
number one is do you overwrite what's
there like so copy file as I think it's
called overwrite target as an option
okay look at that copy file
yeah overwrite target okay so let's like
but but but that's a very simple
question which is you know there's
something you know there's something
already there you want to overwrite it
okay so that's an option that we should
have for both cloud publish and cloud
deploy in my view I think it would make
sense yeah I mean right now the behavior
is to just overwrite so the default
would be true yeah well yeah I do I do
think having the default set to true was
probably what we wants I think so
definitely think so um but then this
what I call clean publish though deals
with a somewhat separate question right
which is more related to synchronization
yes okay let's look at the other ones
here before we before we address that
one because that one I think is deeply
involved with synchronization so file
types that's a filter for what to what
to publish exactly and there's another
filter which isn't within this
documentation which isn't part of file
types and that's the the narrative
paragraph there right before the options
lists the cloud published will not
publish sub directories which begin with
the period so that's another kind of a
soldier - yeah okay so there's there's
there's some filtering in directories
okay so let's take a look and so there's
a couple of possibilities dot files and
there's some file extension
okay okay so then what we want to do
here is some let's take a look at a file
system map okay because it has some of
these a suit okay whatever it does um
all right so file system map I
it has exclusions like that Oh file name
forms
right all of these are actually
interesting okay so this this one here
right that makes sense to people
filename forms would be you know and we
could have various string versions of
that um I don't know exactly how max
items doesn't seem totally stupid either
question mark not certain about that one
okay file name forms really isn't very
well documented and it doesn't like you
know indicating the documentation that
it takes a little list for example which
I sure hope it does well we should check
that it does my godfather file system
app was already from 2016 time flies um
okay actually an interesting suggestion
from me from our livestream about copy
file suggesting the copy file uses the
success mechanism I like that idea
what does copy file a return now oh it
returns the name of the file it copied
does it yeah and I think if you use a
cloud object you get the public cloud
object
as opposed to returning a success object
hmm interesting well at the very least
we we should have some kind of progress
dialogue is that feasible the copy file
an option no it's something that just
always happens if it's big yeah I don't
think you want it to always happen well
it obviously doesn't happen if it if in
the first five seconds it doesn't happen
right I mean if it's inside production
code where does that you know go
anywhere where does it go doesn't go
anywhere I mean this is when it's a
top-level thing you know when it would
be writing the output to a notebook
anyway it does seem like a sensible
suggestion to me in the case where you
know we're look you know you have an
input line it says copy file it's like
it would be very nice to see what's
happening particularly if it's big right
if it ever came out of a system function
what would you think about that horrible
no I mean this is really a creature of
the top level I mean I don't know
whether we are currently suppressing
monitoring I mean this is a project this
is a larger project to talk about
monitoring um and I I think we need a
notion just like you know when you get
an image and you put it in a list it's a
different size so similarly with
monitoring there's monitoring that you
want to have happen at top level and you
don't want to DIF this if it's a sub
operation you owe no air so like a
related thing is you know when we're
loading some neural net but we're using
a function which isn't obviously under
all that function I think that's
that's another yeah it's actually this
is part of Sushma's project maybe Sushma
has now handed it off to somebody else
to you know to deal with these progress
dialogues we should kick in whose is
Matt the one who's peeing here yes okay
so can you communicate that to Sushma
that we should talk about this in
connection with that yes if I land those
things and also this notion of sub you
know whether whether you report on
progress if it's a sub operation okay so
the question here is should cloud deploy
have a file name forms option should
even even file have a file name forms
option in other words if file represents
a directory because we don't have a
wrapper called directory unfortunately
forget what I'm saying I mean one way we
could do it is we could say cloud deploy
of file of path comma file name forms
arrow blah blah blah and that could
represent the deployment with those file
name forms I kind of prefer to have it
inside the cloud deploy I think what do
other people think
I find it inside the file it seems
really weird yeah okay so I don't think
this is unreasonable and I mean I think
this could you know so what would it do
if you tried to deploy this is only
relevant if you're deploying files right
and I don't know whether cloud deploy
has any other sort of type specific
options here
what the heck is meta-information doing
specific arbitrary key value pairs that
you can it can be applied to any cloud
object do people do it yes how do you
get meta information back again options
options object comma meta information
okay so this filename forms thing is a
little bit of a different animal here
okay
beau but I just don't think it's worth
us having a cloud deploy directory it's
not just directory I mean it'll be you
know what happens if the local object is
a directory for instance
what happens if it's a cloud object as a
directory do we know that
so given that you have a cloud object
can a clock can a cloud object be a
directory yep okay I was not aware of
that this things to me so okay okay so
then this would return if this was a
directory this returns a directory cloud
object sorry can I just ask one
clarifying question do all directories
have corresponding cloud objects or do
you have to do something to synthesize a
cloud object well depends on how you
created there at the directory same with
you know cloud objects versus raw files
no we're talking about things in the
cloud object store is it the case that
every directory in the cloud object
store has a cloud object yeah that
should be okay so like there's a cloud
object for the published directory yep
okay I didn't know but that's
interesting okay so then then that's the
return form in the case where okay so so
in other words a typical cloud I might
do the following I might say cloud
publish of file of pic stock JPEG and
then that's a fine thing which would
wind up as a cloud object that has blah
blah blah blah blah JPEG correct yep yep
assuming
we keep the name basically which we
should right now if you do a cloud
publish of a single argument it will
create an unnamed cloud object but it
but of course that's because by default
everything is an expression which does
not fundamentally have a name yeah okay
so that's an interesting thing
preserving the name of the file I think
we should preserve the name of the file
right yeah yeah okay and if you don't
want it preserved so what happens if
that collides with the file you already
have that's a target
overwrite target I would argue I would
argue that in this case there's a scary
case here where the name happened -
isn't there an override target or
automatic to deal with the scary case
where there happened to be a file name
well do we know this I mean if you if
you deployed from that file before
hunky-dory but if you deployed it
deployed your prize expression to that
name then you happen to have a file that
has the same name as the thing you
deployed to you deploy that that's a bit
unfortunate well I mean it's you know
there are two bad options here one bad
option is that you over wrote your thing
just by you know not paying attention to
the file name the other bad option is
that you can evaluate your thing once
and then it won't evaluate properly
again until you add overwrite target
true to it I think one thing for the
design though is the club publish
typically is describes making a copy
right so if like hopefully your source
of truth for some your prize expression
isn't in your published directory oh
that's true cloud Pacific our publishers
okay in that regard
cloud deploy it's less obvious okay
hey there's interesting comment from
ethan on the live stream first of all
he's complaining that delete file
returns null which I agree is pretty
stupid I mean I don't see why that
shouldn't return success what
break things to do that do you think I
mean it seems reasonable from my
perspective but I'm not sure if we have
the right people to comment if there are
any unexpected issues let's bring that
up in the LCC meeting could we move at
that please um sure okay he also
comments on the dry run option um which
apparently AWS and a sink have that is
an interesting idea
I wonder if rather than having it be an
option it would be a rapper I think it
should be a rapper let's let's let's
look at that for a second I think it's a
very good idea yeah um it's related a
little bit to sandbox into what would
the rapper look like I mean would it be
and don't evaluate I think this is a bit
scary but but I mean it's possible I
something like this would that be
possible
I don't see why not and then it would
return successful failure mayor it and
gosh you know it might have the option
for you know returning the operations
returning or printing I'm not sure which
would be the best the operations that
you know that were called because it cuz
of course you know this might be buried
deep inside a function well you can do
an echo if you want that then if you
want to see and it's buried echo it I
mean I mean I think it is you can't
publish a directory and you're gonna see
what files specifically are copied I
mean I mean I think the point is a dry
run is you want to see what what it's
what it would do what things it touches
yeah
I wish there was something less less
metaphorical and dry-run what will be
something a little bit more um it's kind
of like using a block to virtualize your
filesystem or something that's not quite
the right analogy but what do you what
it's been anything do this but without
actually executing any side effects at
least side effects on a file system or
cloud system yeah do this without doing
it in other words don't do it what
reports the side effects
yeah yeah right right um what what would
this do is really the the what it's some
but how do we say that I mean what's an
analogous thing where we where we don't
do it where we I mean this is a general
thing of something which would have side
effects um you know so MacGyver
never been clear on because we you know
we've had some sandbox functionality but
I guess is it true that none of the
sandbox stuff is mated to the system
contexts I believe that's correct I mean
we'd certainly sandbox plenty of things
in the cloud and so on right because
because I mean it's a bit like that you
know I imagine if you had a sandbox that
you could wrap around things in the
system context and then it would throw
the sandbox exceptions of things that
tried to escape the sandbox
yeah but the point is though that that I
mean this is this is a everything is
escaping right I mean we might want a
general I I'm just I'm not saying the
two concepts are the same but they're
similar yeah I do like this concept
I mean constrained evaluators the thing
we plan for the sandbox but this is a
different thing where how complicated
this is this code wise to do dry run
versions of things like copy file I
don't think anyone in this meeting can
answer that okay all right let's come
back but I should think that you know in
the kernel at least I mean you know
obviously something like a library link
or whatever could escape it but I should
think that in the kernel that we've
already basically bracketed all the file
operations with sandbox code so it
should I would think we would be able to
implement something you know that hooks
into the sandbox code for this what it
can't do of course is it can't just
throw an exception and fail you know and
have to continue on that's the one main
difference yeah I mean this is not gonna
do anything this is going to be um I
mean I mean in that sense it's the same
as the sandbox the sandbox doesn't
actually do it but what if it right I
understand I understand I mean it's more
like report effects of delete file but
even that's not quite right I mean it's
it's like would this work
we need a better name for it but I
I think the concept is good and if it we
don't cover it here we should cover it
in the LCC meeting ya think this very
place okay yes all right
let's come back to this question you're
clean publish versus the synchronization
question okay okay so we've got this
notion of cloud deploying cloud publish
and we've got it for a directory
and and I think this all seems quite
implementable right well but but I would
want you know finally in forms for
something like it with these symbolic
categories that I defined I think that's
really useful fine
I think we need to look at file name
forms um which means I'm not sure who
implemented who implements it was that
Nick or Fahim or somebody who
implemented the file name map file
system map I can't remember who
implemented that that's part of the ILD
team we need to find those people and
make sure they're in a meeting to talk
about what happens with their with the
file name forms thing because actually
it's incompatible right now what it says
file name forms claims it's taking a
string pattern right and this wouldn't
be a string pattern in fact it's not a
string pattern it is it is a file name
pattern which is different at least I'm
pretty sure that's what's going on here
okay all right well I don't know maybe
it is a string pattern I don't know but
it but I wouldn't be so you know that's
a distinction which I suspect is allows
forms of the same type as in file names
so yeah
okay but I would claim whatever is
necessary here is useful for file names
as well sure
okay so this is a separate discussion we
need to we need to have about this okay
and this stuff can be implemented
without this I mean we can put in
whatever we want for file name for us we
don't have these symbolic forms for file
name form seems useful but it's also
part of file names itself all right
something for LCC yeah Matt you got that
yes okay do we keep the dot file special
D orthogonal to this or come on no I
think this should be part of this I
think we should just default to not do
it I mean you know family informs our
automatic would default to not keep dot
files
how would you specify that to not keep a
dart file but to use everything else I
don't know probably wouldn't accept this
I don't think it does so this is a bit
of a mess we need to unscramble this
okay but let's keep going on the
question of synchronization okay okay so
mother we don't forget the overwrite
target option right Joel that's probably
for you right yep
and and we should generate a failure
object of one of these things fails I
assume we do that already
right it doesn't right now now what does
it do right now it issues a message and
returns dollar failed okay we should
return a failure object okay okay so
let's come back to this question about
um
[Music]
okay and so to be clear the the extra
sauce here is that in the cloud were we
would have the option to just outright
delete files that don't exist locally
yeah I understand it I understand that I
want to point out another thing this
should work that should obviously work
right what would he do very clear I mean
wouldn't you know it's gonna publish
it's gonna be putting it in the
published directory okay right it's
going to copy that and publish it but if
it's already there that's gonna give an
error probably okay object if you do
publish of an anonymous cloud object
there's no name we can I understand I
don't know but but now notice here that
when you do that the top-level directory
so it would actually go to published how
much / yeah that's the first element of
the filename take of minus 1 of that
path yeah which I think I may have
actually said in their cloud poetry
documentation okay all right let's go
back here we need to talk about the the
the UX let me just understand that and I
want to come back to this in the in the
desktop we're going to have presumably
so published a cloud is for a specific
notebook in focus right for now yeah um
well I wonder
that dialogue matter we shouldn't go
wipe like that okay so I wonder whether
that dialogue could have or whether it
gets too complicated at the top could
say basically what do you want to
publish and that the default is to
publish this notebook so it so it says
it's publishing this notebook you see
what I'm saying and if you could pick
another notebook that's probably the
cleanest way to do it it's a little
funky that it would come up whatever
notebook is in focus it would come up
asking to publish that notebook but I
guess it's the same thing as saying well
it's either it's either that or we add
another menu item I don't think there
are any other reasonable choices yeah I
agree but do you what do you think about
this one where we make it so that I
think it's nice to show what you're
going to publish just in case you've got
that you were confused about what was in
focus or something like that yeah well
in an ideal world you know that dialogue
would be attached to the notebook in
some way so that you know you could tell
by virtue of his attachments but yeah I
think this is I think that's probably
okay
all right so we'll need a design for
that I hope that won't make the dialog
too complicated
well you know I always push back against
complexities so well I mean maybe add
another menu item it's better what would
it say but know what I'm saying it is
did you know before that UX reaches you
if it's fraught with complexity I'm
gonna push back on it so okay but so
saved cloud would have the same no well
that's the coolant of cloud deploy the
heck is that doing this is hopefully
getting changed right this is horrifying
it's being worked on but it's a it's a
large amount of work so but it is being
worked on yes okay okay but but then
wouldn't this have
behavior that it says what you're saving
I mean it's a little weird because it
already is telling you what you're
saving here and whatever the pull-down
is that says what you're saving how tell
you what you're saving is telling you
the name I know that you're saving it
too it's not telling you what you're
saving it I know I know
so okay back back backing up here okay
okay so synchronization so what we're
saying is um when you do this and that
would be relevant for cloud deploy as
well as cloud publish it's nothing
special about publish right say miss you
I suppose yeah I just say I admit to not
having thought as much about the cloud
deploy side of things but okay so the
other way round of take the cloud and
check it out into my local file system
that's a different function again right
yeah
well you know even if you look at
something like our sink you know our
sake has you know has a direction to it
you know there's a sender and a receiver
and the behaviors will be different
depending on which side is a sender and
which side is a receiver okay but how do
we I mean in our case I see what you're
saying so what we could do is we could
say cloud synchronize and then we
give either a local file name well okay
so then then let's imagine we did this
that's doing this operation of a clean
because this thing about clean publishes
only relevant second time round it's not
relevant first time around because
there's nothing there first time around
right um I think in modern world times
we could get away with cloud sync um I
think that's a word it is but as for I'm
but I might prefer sy NC all right yeah
but yes both forms are legal Scrabble
words in case now okay okay so then okay
so this case yeah so is so if you're
looking at the you know the are sick
model you know like I said there's a
direction and you could you know and
basically what you're doing is you're
pushing stuff from the sender to the
receiver you have to declare who their
sender and who the receiver is right but
so the thing that I'm interested in is
the one argument case of this where it
knows by default where I put that right
so then effectively what we've got is
cloud sync rules arrow you know this
puppy is corresponds to you know like
their pairs that that thing corresponds
to cloud object of whatever and that
could
perfectly well be generated by I mean we
could perfectly well have a dollar cloud
sync rules but I don't know how we would
keep this I mean it would have to be
some kind of persistent value but it
will be generated when you do a cloud
publish or a cloud deploy I'm making
sense no we mean it would be generated
the synchronization okay what is synced
with what if you say cloud publish my
local file my local directory -
somewhere in the cloud then the system
would remember
oh yes that local directory is
associated with that thing in the cloud
so if I then poke it by saying cloud
sync of that local directory it knows oh
yeah that one was was deployed to the
cloud in this place okay that seems like
a very natural operation for a user user
interface but a very dangerous operation
for a language construct don't disagree
I don't disagree so I'd be perfectly
happy to see that only be in the user
interface and that you have to specify
it explicitly so that then this would
not be allowed initially okay so the
user interface we're saying here ok so
then there will be an additional thing
here sync with cloud right unclear what
sync with cloud would do that saves a
cloud wouldn't in your world because it
could go the other way
no but that's sync is a misnomer that's
not actually what sync does you
the way around that is to to yo you can
sync from cloud yes yes no you couldn't
sync to cloud you could sync from cloud
from cloud to your way why can't you
think to cloud well I mean because
that's I mean well you can but that's
what save already would be doing
I understand but conceptually
conceptually sync but it save might be
doing that or might not be doing that
depending on what we do for this this
clean you know
what the default is for this will be
capable of doing is what I mean
right if with that option so my argument
would be there's a separate function in
the system called cloud sync that
effectively has that option right that
would have the option you know whatever
the name is of that option about whether
it whether it deletes files and so on
and that's the thing but that save by
default wouldn't be in that business
never be in the business of magically
deleting files it would just you know
produce put more files there okay and
then that the sync with cloud would have
a sync from cloud sync to cloud that
both of those are possibilities from it
and that then in the UI so to speak and
that then um think that makes sense to
me
okay so the first
we're gonna see here by the way I don't
know whether we've had the discussion
here but we whether you guys already
figured it out this business about
promoting the published directory so
it's not in the home directory did you
guys work that out already remember the
thing we talked about last week remember
remember I mean what do you think did
you work on a directory would move
somewhere else yeah that's what that's
what we wanted to do okay um there's an
interesting suggestion from Sandra on
our live stream beware you've got a low
background noise by the way a lot of
background noise um about this that you
could say something like sandboxed of
delete file
you know let's say sandboxed file
operations
of exper problem with that is I mean
that would be like don't actually do the
file operations although I suppose so
the problem is what then isn't sandboxed
and then what it would do is come back
with a report um you know report on what
happened what would have happened no
that's the thing for the LCC meeting
yeah um okay listen I think we nailed
what we needed to nail for this meeting
do you agree so you're suggesting that
we then come up with cloud sync which
still which has an option that we
haven't named yet but has the behavior
that right we ascribe to clean publish I
think I think what it is what that one
would be is something like something
like um um did I put cloud my cloud sync
thing you know it's something like sync
file structures Harrow true or false or
something or what what is it really
doing it's deleting files that weren't
there
right so it's it's it's taking the
overwrite as assumed but then the
question is does it then actually delete
as well okay but so cloud sync then
would have would have the overwrite
target option
yes that's perfectly reasonable okay so
the next one is you know delete absent
files basically is what it comes down to
right yeah
delete missing files delete absent files
I think missing is
more common more easily understood
it's a little weird given the delete
missing that we have to light
non-conforming files sounds that sounds
deeply there's some kind of bizarre
political correctness overtone to that
yes um dystopian something-or-other ah
shades of the Apple 1984 commercial
um well I think we could start off with
delete missing files although I don't
particularly like that I don't like it
because of the corresponds with delete
delete absent files delete I think being
able to say directly the word delete
delete non corresponding files awfully
long but that is kind of what it is
you I well be
that as it may I guess then my job is to
write a cloud sync page which takes all
this into it I think so I my preference
of the ones listed here is delete absent
files okay
Matt can you make sure that this
notebook can you email that to me yes
Joel and others it's it's get the file
wrapper to work inside cloud deploy and
so on right mm-hmm
okay I like this design I think this is
all quite good until one questions are
so in a sense of cloud think we're fine
with it not necessarily being to way
that it you know make sure that you have
the same thing on both ends after well
well I'm thinking that what we could do
in the future is some kind of actually
you know I'm not sure what you mean by
two-way I mean and you know it's you
can't literally synchronize things you
know I mean you can't literally do a
two-way sync because you have to have
you know a reference you know you do a
three-way sake so you know clouds right
right so close so so cloud sync is
really it's it's a push or a pull some
time to clear we could do it like this
possibly although I have to say that
then copy files should probably accept
that also copy file except the rule
what's that oh sorry I didn't see what
you were typing okay because that way if
we did in the future have two-way sync
we could use a two-way ruler when I talk
about the impossibility of two-way sync
I mean unless you back up the system
with a unless you back up both sides
with version control it's just it's not
an implementation problem it just can't
be done because the information is gone
yeah okay well I still okay that's a
that that's why a three-way sake is what
works be
as you you know the you know the third
component is the thing which was the
progenitor of the other two I understand
but what I'd want it to do is you know
versions or not is to say keep my
filesystem low you know like what
Dropbox would do for example what is
Dropbox it's a it's a you know in what
sense is that well well well Dropbox
does IIIi don't know all the ways in
which Dropbox resolves these issues but
Dropbox has the capability to do
versioning and to do three-way but the
basic point is that sinking to the
master copy in the Dropbox cloud yeah
that's what you're basically saying
everything is syncing to that yes there
is no master right that's exactly
correct now you're you basically you're
designating the master by saying which
side is on the left-hand side of the
rule yeah if we do it with rules but I
don't think we have it I think we should
do it just with commas okay um all right
excellent guys okay people are following
livestream they're about to do one about
quantum mechanics and quantum computing
all right
talk to y'all soon great bye thanks